- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to talk about
cellular respiration,
which sounds like a very fancy thing,
but it's really just about
the biochemical processes
that can take things
that we find in food and convert
it into forms of energy that we can use
to do things like run and
maintain our body temperature,
and maintain body homeostasis.
So to get into the chemistry
of cellular respiration,
and this really is an overview video,
we will start with the chemical
equation for respiration.
And what it's all about is a series
of steps that when you
look at them in aggregate,
you're starting with the
glucose right over here,
using oxygen, and that's why we have
to breathe really hard in order
to do our cellular respiration.
And it's going to yield
some carbon dioxide,
which we also need to
breathe hard to exhale,
some water, and some energy.
Now that energy he is in the form of heat,
which can help us maintain
our body temperature,
especially if it's cold outside side.
But also ATP.
Now you might be wondering, what is ATP?
And to help us answer that question,
I will show you a picture of ATP,
and I will also show you a picture
of glucose or a visualization of it.
Now you don't have to memorize
what these structures are,
but what's really going
on here is that glucose,
as you are able to shape
it into other things,
as you're able to break
the bonds in glucose,
and having its constituents
form bonds with other things,
that has a net release of energy.
And that energy can be used
to stake what's next
as a DP that has two phosphate groups,
and add a third phosphate
group onto it right over here.
Now you see it might
say, why is that useful?
Why is that a more readily
usable form of energy?
Well, as you go forward
in your biological journey
or your understanding of biology,
you'll see that ATP molecules like this,
by losing that phosphate
and allowing that phosphate
to bond to other things
can actually release energy
and can fuel muscles,
can fuel other biological processes.
Now to understand the steps of it,
we will start in the cytosol of a cell,
where a process known as
glycolysis takes place.
And glycolysis literally
means the breaking of glucose.
So let me write it down, glycolysis.
And what it does is it
breaks each glucose molecule
into two molecules known as pyruvate.
Now just that process alone,
and we'll go into much
more depth in other videos,
does start to produce some ATPs,
and also helps produce some
molecules known as NADH.
And I know this is all
sounding very complex.
But you will have a
molecule known as NAD+,
if you want to know what it looks like,
it looks like this.
Once again, don't get too
bogged down in the details.
It is worth noting,
NAD stands for nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide.
And we also noticed that ATP stands
for adenosine triphosphate.
And so you have these
very molecular components
that are showing up in
different places in biology,
and you might also
recognize that adenosine
is involved in the
formation of DNA as well.
So once again,
these molecules are adapted
and reused all over the place.
But going back to our journey
of cellular respiration, an NAD+ molecule,
if you were to add to
that two hydrogen protons,
and this is the important
part, two electrons,
it will be reduced to NADH.
And remember, reduction is
the gaining of electrons,
which is happening right over here.
And the reason why these two electrons
are really interesting is,
in NADH, they're in a
fairly high energy state.
And as we'll see,
as they're able to go to other molecules
and go to lower and lower energy states,
they're able to do useful things
that can eventually end up
in the production of ATP.
It's essentially a transfer of energy.
So glycolysis is directly
producing some ATPs,
and it's also reducing NAD
in this way to produce NADH.
For the next stage, we have
to go into the mitochondria,
which is often known as
the powerhouse of the cell,
where now our pyruvate will enter
into the mitochondrial
matrix right over here.
And that's where the
citric acid cycle occurs.
And the citric acid cycle
is going to use a derivative
of the pyruvate, which
we got from glycolysis.
You don't have to know all the details,
it's called acetylcholine.
But that's going to go through
a series of transformations.
And the reason why it's called a cycle,
there's some molecules that
react with the acetyl-CoA,
and then through a series
of transformations,
get back to where they started.
And the reason why it's
called a citric acid cycle
is one of those intermediaries is citrate.
But this process, once again,
produces more ATPs directly,
but it also produces more NADHs,
and it also is able to
do something similar
to another molecule.
And once again, I'm not going
to go into all of the details.
But we're able to go
from another molecule,
known as flavin adenine dinucleotide, FAD,
plus two hydrogen protons,
plus two electrons to get to FADH2,
which once again is an
interesting molecule,
because it has these electrons
in a higher energy level,
which, through a series
of molecular processes,
which you'll go into much
detail in future courses on,
you are able to do useful work.
You're able to transfer energy.
So once you have a few ATPs
and a bunch of NADHs and FADHs,
you then go into something known
as the electron transport chain.
And this is essentially
where those electrons go
from a high energy state
and they get transferred
from one molecule to another,
actually along this
membrane right over here.
And as they do, the proteins
that they are interacting with are able
to use that energy in order
to pump hydrogen protons
into this intermembrane
space of the mitochondria.
And then that concentration
gradient of hydrogen protons,
it's released through another enzyme,
which is actually able to
produce the actual ATP.
So I know that is a lot to process,
but this is meant to be just an overview.
I know you might have a lot of questions
as I did the first time
that I learned this.
But the important thing to realize,
that glucose does store energy,
but we don't use it directly.
We have to go through cellular respiration
to convert that glucose into ATPs,
which is more readily used by cells.
Now the various steps are also going
to produce heat as they release energy,
which could also be useful for the cell.
Now, one final point, you
might say glucose, well,
that's only one form of food.
You showed a picture of bread initially.
Well, carbohydrates are made up of chains
of simple sugars like glucose.
And if we're thinking about things
like protein or fats, which
you could also use for energy,
those are going to be adapted
and enter at different phases
of cellular respiration.
But at some point, you're going
to have a very similar process.
So I lied, I actually
have one last, last point.
We talked a lot about glucose
as it enters into glycolysis,
and then the pyruvate enters
into the mitochondria.
But what about the oxygen?
Where's that involvement as an input?
Well, the oxygen is the
eventual electronic sector
at the end of the
electron transport chain.
And not only is it accepting electrons,
it's accepting hydrogen protons.
So the oxygen is an input into
the electron transport chain.
And then once it gets those electrons
and those hydrogen protons,
well, you can imagine what the output is.
You add some oxygen to some
hydrogen protons and electrons,
you're going to get water.
You're going to get this
output right over here.
And what about the carbon dioxide?
Well, the carbon dioxide
is going to be an output
of the citric acid cycle.